Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Interesting.
There you go.
All right,
let's get into it.
So excited.
There's so many things to discuss.
A lot of fun going on in this episode.
Really?
Uh,
all right.
Oh,
Here we go.
Gene.
He
shout out to everybody.
Justin says,
hey guys,
Marty is jacked.
He keeps his jeans high and tight.
Sure he does.
That's true.
Yes.
I seen him with Jane's.
Very high.
Very high rate.
Too tight and big arms.
Okay.
Actually he's a,
I dunno,
he's,
you think he's bigger than you are with respect to muscles?
I don't know.
Oh,
is Randy?
Don't bring anyone loving to live.
No Bar.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
No.
Uh,
did you know that g one,
uh,
Eto?
Why?
Yes,
I did.
I heard.
Yeah.
No,
someone said that he lips inked or something.
Yeah,
he got ripped apart by country music fans.
He lip sync on the CMA,
the country music awards or whatever that is.
And he's such a good entertainer.
He doesn't,
he doesn't need to do that.
So you wouldn't fucking do that.
Where their walker June.
That's right.
Well he would have sung that shit
but all wheeler has been banned from those uh,
Oilers and banned from ever.
He's about,
I think we're going to see all wheeler on the Supreme Court and argue in his
case that he's being censored.
Target Walmart.
They won't plug play.
They will play as shit.
Fucking too dangerous man.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's why I entertainer of the year.
That is just so crazy.
How does one be alert?
Major G SWAPO sweat.
I up here,
he's still terrible.
His Instagram stories and I watch every one of them.
I 11 I cherish them cause they're so shitty.
Dude.
I love by the way,
this shit,
when a nerd that's happened over the course of the show a bunch of times.
No,
but like when our listeners get a shout out on like a new thing,
Justin says,
hey guys,
Marty is jacked.
He keeps his jeans high and tight.
That's true.
Yes.
And then they have no idea what's going on.
It brought me back to look what's on page one of my drops page.
What's that?
Monkey Todd.
I remember the original he got on TMZ on there.
Uh,
the ones that they take call and I think of the Internet show.
Yeah.
And he got Harvey Levin.
That was the first time we ever loved Harvey 11.
The first time we ever had a mommy sabotaged.
Yeah.
This is page one.
This was like right when the show started.
He was talking about where the dude,
I guess that's just the Harvey Harvey,
but he caught on,
I remember he was like,
all right.
He's like,
you know where the dudes are at heart.
Ah,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is great cause this is like a local radio local news show,
like a local affiliate.
Rochester,
New York.
I think that's what they said.
This is two square.
For those of you who aren't watching on youtube,
like two total.
You know,
Predator likes new SAS guys.
Like they're funny,
but they're,
you know,
they're sweet.
They're nice guys.
Yeah.
I mean they're kind of boners but they're like nice,
funny guys.
I got bamboozled by a mommy.
That's what happens,
man.
Play with mom.
You never know what's gonna Happen.
You know,
Shit gets real time made me laugh.
I like that stuff a lot.
I fucking love that stuff.
It's like,
it kind of is.
Um,
you know,
to me it reminds me of the,
hey mommy,
thanks gene.
Stuff.
Drive through.
I almost forgot about how much fun that was.
You shouldn't,
if you listened to the show now,
um,
I can't,
you know,
give it that much context all at this moment.
But you look up,
I think there's are some on youtube if you look up,
hey mommy,
thanks jeans.
With relation to your mom's house is where we got people to go to drive throughs
and basically refer,
like use jokes from the show in their drive through orders and his amazing,
well and it's something that in private life you and I still practice all the
time.
We decided to actually have fun for the first time in a long time and we took
off the rest of the afternoon and we went to eat Italian food and then we went
to a movie and everybody we call mommy or genes or genes.
Mommy,
you're just,
and nobody still to this day.
And even like the guy shaved Parmesan onto my plate and I go,
wow,
good job jeans.
You're welcome.
Like it doesn't register.
Nobody has.
And saying good job to somebody is like,
especially if you act impressed,
like good job jeans at Shaving Parmesan,
you know,
something to applaud someone.
I think he just thought like,
this guy's a fucking idiot.
It's two or drunk.
Yeah.
Good job.
Good.
Chad.
Really impressed when you poured that water chains.
Good job.
And then we saw the most boring movie on the fucking plan.
I kind of regret switching it.
We're going to go see Thor,
which was like everyone's raving about,
but I was like,
I don't want to see that shit.
I just didn't care.
Well,
you're not a comic book now.
I played sports growing up,
so yeah.
But yeah,
there's a different word for them too.
But um,
yeah.
So I went,
I saw a murder in a title and I was like,
let's go see that.
I knew that would make your bring joy to your heart.
So we saw murder on the Orient Express,
which is based on the Agatha Christie book from 1902 and felt like they filmed
it.
Yeah.
I mean it's a little doll because it's once it's one backdrop and Johnny Depp's
in it and he's a customer
dragged.
And then there also was the,
I dunno,
um,
you know,
in,
in a thriller where there's new suspicion,
you do need to like lead people and then misdirect and then,
but when you do it like 10,
11 times,
it also starts snowing.
Yeah.
It just starts to be annoying when you don't clue the audience in on how the
detective is coming to his conclusions.
Well,
he'll be like,
they won't even show anything.
He'd be like,
I noticed a scrape and the painting and you're like,
what painting?
We never saw that.
So he just did do some shit with like superhero style.
I noticed that you farther when you walked in the room.
All right.
And then that means you must have breakfast eight.
That's impressive.
Yeah.
Well,
one thing that really bothered us and this film,
uh,
Dame Judi Dench isn't it?
And she's,
she's fine.
I mean I could watch her do anything and she has two little lap dogs too.
I thought she had one.
I thought it was till and the whole time.
I mean I was concerned because I'm like,
where are these dogs shitting and pissing on the train and they never show him
going,
I never talk about it.
It's kind of like the Martian movie with Matt Damon where they're like,
where do you jerk off and when are you,
how come you're not watching porn when you ask for stuff?
Was it bothered me about this film?
Much like the Matt Damon Film,
Why aren't you answering the important questions?
Like yes we know who done it,
but where are these malteses taking their shits in there?
PICIS cause you're on this train for days.
It's what the next movie will probably be about as what I'm thinking when they
do a sequel,
where,
where did the dog shit and Piss.
What a neat pitch.
And also like I watch people on airplanes taking international flights with
their dogs and I think like,
well,
how are those dog's pissing and shitting all their movie?
It could be a movie about that or a television series you're thinking,
yeah,
that's right.
I thought we could,
you know,
I know you have some TV meetings coming up.
You could too.
I thought you could pitch that and I thought for the dog's pissing and shitting,
you could call it.
Where do I go?
You Go,
where do I go now?
Let me give you some advice.
When you,
when you walk in and you go,
where do I go?
And they'll be like,
well,
I'd be like,
that's all I talked to you about.
It's a show about dogs shitting and pissing in places that you don't know where
they're going and then they'll be like,
oh,
that's intriguing.
Yes,
they go and then you go,
I need,
I need three acts and I need 22 minutes and I can blow people's minds in this
country.
I have a feeling I should open with you guys.
Are Dog lovers.
Right.
That's true.
I don't feel like that's the way to get them on board.
And then I could be like,
but where do they go when people are on train the cars start with like your
phone and go hold it up like that.
And you showed me like as a picture of my dog and they're like,
oh that's adorable.
And be like,
do you know where he shit and piss today?
And then they'll be like,
I'm sorry he went in the backyard cause he was home.
But what about when you see a dog on a plane?
You know like right away you grab them in like that.
And then if they don't like that one,
I was thinking I could follow it up.
Okay,
well that,
not that one,
but what about dog tick afternoon,
which was one of the original great ideas on this show.
A pitch where you take different breeds of dogs on a walk and you explain to the
viewing audience their habits and behavior and you know the history of the dog
and then you masturbate the two dogs and then you see if they have different
styles of orgasm.
I'm thinking ABC cause they do racier stuff.
This is more in line like a Fox show and then thinking of hosting you of course.
Wow.
Your show.
Okay.
What movie?
Cesar Milan,
you know,
cute blonde and you go like hey guys,
you like dogs.
And then at the end of the dog episode the dogs come.
So right now you have a show pitching,
shitting and pissing and coming.
I can't think of a,
a more exciting talent moving forward for the networks.
Do you think our manager would like,
what is he going to like?
I would tell him,
I would say this,
I have a couple of great ideas.
I want to surprise you.
Don't tell him,
tell him the pitches and advance at all in advanced.
Just drop it on him in the room and I'm sure he'll be like,
yeah,
it'll really get on board with it.
I had known him a long time.
Yeah,
he'll like it.
He didn't like it and he'll like it a lot.
I really like this idea,
but I am serious.
That was distracting me the entire time as a dog lover.
I was very upset at the idea of Dame Judi Dench keeping this dog hostage on this
train.
Very,
yeah,
I'm serious though.
How do you think that they let the dog piss and shit on the Orient Express?
That's really good question.
I mean,
I don't know how they did it period in that era.
I feel like now we live in an era where they're like,
they'll build an area for dogs airport.
There's like relief area for dogs,
but that's just like the 1930s or something twenties I think.
Yeah,
like I guess I just let it Piss and shit where it wanted,
I sent got depressing too when they were unfolding the stone.
Fuck.
Real bummer.
Really fucked me in the ass,
man.
Really fuck me harder.
Fuck me and my asshole.
I didn't like that.
Uh,
what is this a question for you,
Amy?
Emit Topia.
Oh,
I'm at a phobia.
What does that,
I'm an a metaphor,
but I don't like vomiting.
Oh,
okay.
I've talked about it before on a,
that's deep bro.
I talked about on this show actually.
Yeah.
Okay,
good.
I love advice on this one.
Some advice regarding,
what is it phobia.
I'm a 33 year old woman.
I've been suffering for over 20 years.
How were you able to go through with pregnancy?
My biological clock is ticking with the thought of morning sickness is
terrifying.
Thanks Amanda.
Amanda,
I hear you because I had the same exact fear when I was pregnant with Ellis and
I will tell you that I never vomited with him.
So first of all,
it's a metaphor via is a phobia of vomiting.
And I've had it since I was like nine years old,
a long time.
I don't like hearing that,
you know,
I don't like it.
I'm going to rip off my head close
anyways.
Um,
it helped me to talk about it with my therapist.
If you have a therapist,
I would recommend doing that.
And then I will tell you that when I was pregnant with Ellis,
I would get nauseous,
but I would will it away.
But the other thing,
but then you told me later on,
somebody told you about a medicine.
Yeah.
So here's what you can take.
Full disclosure,
I'm not Rick recommending you take this and you talk to your physician.
Don't fucking,
I didn't make you take it.
You have to ask.
All right.
Yeah.
So there's a medicine that can suppress the spasms in your stomach.
Uh,
so again,
like that is something you can ask your doctor to prescribe you if you have a
severe subscribe,
prescribed subscribe.
Did I say fucking subscribed?
But you're correcting my,
I'm thank you so much.
You're right.
Yeah,
I got a subscription for it cause it's actually,
I mean I've read about it.
Let's say you have food poisoning.
It's not necessary for it to come out of your stomach.
I can go out the other way,
which is why a doctor would prescribe subsys sorry,
subscribe it.
There you go.
Yeah.
So you can,
will it away.
And I have,
and maybe I'm just lucky
all the time.
I've known you,
not one,
not one.
How many years have known you a long,
but let's say we've been together.
I mean we started dating and oh five.
So yeah.
Yes.
I have 12 years.
Knock on wood,
I have not vomited over when I got food poisoning.
I don't like talking about it,
but I remember in the sink and I didn't like it.
And I remember seeing the green parts of it and I fucking flipped out.
Flipped out quietly.
Yeah.
Well I've learned to contain my anxiety.
Like I get it and I'm so afraid of when Ellis is going to get food or stomach
problems cause it's,
it's happy it's going to happen.
It's gonna happen and I'm course I'll be alone with him.
You'll be on the road.
Well,
it's thinking of dog come and be vomiting.
Uh,
great.
Speaking of dog come and vomiting,
uh,
Jesus Christ,
what kind of Segue,
what are we going to go into now?
I thought it makes total sense.
Louis C K has been,
um,
no,
he's one of the titans of art of our industry.
And,
and you know,
obviously if you were alive,
you've paid attention to it.
Probably if you follow comedy,
like comedy podcasts,
you probably well versed in already.
But there's this,
um,
you know,
there's this shakedown going down,
that's probably the wrong term,
but there's this,
uh,
just shakedown good.
Just
down.
It's going down in Hollywood.
No,
it's overall I think it's a,
it's actually a really good thing.
It's like checking some pretty horrible,
uh,
behavior and
behavior that's been known by the way in our community for a long time.
Yeah.
And I'm
about,
I mean,
when I say checking behavior,
I'm talking about a,
across the board.
I think it's good to check,
um,
powerful people that are abusing their power.
Yeah.
And I think obviously the Weinstein one is massive and he's over.
He's been raping people.
He crazy.
And then,
you know,
I made some jokes initially about the spacey one.
Yeah.
Because,
uh,
I,
you know,
not that it's whatever,
it's not,
it's not like a good thing he was doing,
but I thought he was just kind of being,
uh,
you know,
overly flirtatious on the set.
Like kind of like I said,
he was like rubbing guys shoulders that don't want,
I was like,
oh,
he's just,
he's,
he's doing what some guys do to women,
but to guys on the side of house of cards.
And then stories came out about him with like 14 year old boys.
Nice.
Attempting to rape one,
uh,
supposedly raping another and turns out,
I mean,
at least how it's being portrayed is that he's a fucking savage,
you know?
Um,
and I think those guys will never work again and should never work again and
some,
and I think,
you know,
I think Weinstein might go to prison.
I hope so.
There's,
there active investigations.
He's a real Predator that was open cases on him in La and New York.
Yeah.
So they're like,
they're in their investment
gating,
trying to find a way to charge that guy with a real crime.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
let's,
I mean,
he did go to rehab for three whole days.
Tough.
So let's not forget him and space here at the same place.
Do you know that they're in the same Rehab facility?
Yeah.
Well good for them.
You can compare compare notes,
but what's that Shit Shit head that uh,
raped a 13 year old and he went to Paris.
Oh,
Roman Polanski and has been continued to yeah,
they celebrate it.
Yeah.
She want to show business.
Loves that guy.
Welcome back.
Like what?
I wonder if they're going to further,
you know,
like he's been,
he's been defended by show business people for a long time.
I know it's one of the more alarming things.
If you don't know the Polanski story,
you can read it in detail,
but he was convicted in Los Angeles county of sex with a 13 year old girl in a
hot tub that he gave champagne too.
I don't know if he gave her a pill.
He,
um,
you know,
had an agreement of certain amount of time to be served.
The judge either retired or died.
And so like the replacement judge was like,
no,
you're gonna go to prison for a while.
And his,
his defense,
I'm paraphrasing this stuff,
but like with something about,
yeah.
But the last judge said we had a deal and basically new judge was like,
I don't give a fuck about your deal.
Yeah.
And so he got on a plane to Paris and that's that he's never come back.
He's tried to,
um,
ask for permission to come back.
And Los Angeles district attorney's for the last whatever,
30 years I've been like,
nope,
you have an open warrant for your arrest if you're ever in.
Yeah.
You know,
around,
um,
US territory's or any play anyways,
all that stuff.
Those guys are,
it's horrible.
Um,
with Louie,
you know,
the thing that,
uh,
first of all,
I was just like,
we've heard the stories for a long time,
you know,
uh,
particularly,
yeah.
Let's put it this way.
It's,
it's been in our industry,
we've all known,
the Comedians have spoken about for the last,
I thought it was a one,
one of the things that I'm like,
hm is I'm hearing some of these comics go like,
I didn't know that,
that,
I'm like,
well the thing is too,
you hear stories,
his peer like guys are his age.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Am I gonna let you kind of know that really?
I mean,
the thing is too,
but,
but you know,
again,
if you're in our shoes and you hear a story like that about somebody,
you don't,
you weren't there.
You don't know all the facts.
You don't know.
You don't know what's true,
what's not,
what's,
you know what I mean?
Like stories.
The telephone game is like,
okay.
I don't know.
I don't,
you don't know.
I know anything.
I Dunno.
I,
here's the thing,
my,
my thought on it is that what he did is not okay to do so clearly.
It's really not okay to do that to people.
Um,
especially if like those people are,
you know,
like in a position working for something,
like if they're working under you and like you're the boss basically in the
room.
Right.
Um,
that's the whole thing is that he was in there,
there,
you know,
he's in the position of power and taking advantage of his powerful position.
It's fucked up.
It is,
it is fucked up.
Yeah.
But again,
like is it,
is it worth ruining
someone's entire life?
You're like,
dude,
I have a lot.
I know.
I don't know how this,
I mean if it comes across really callous,
but like when that story broke and when the consequences started,
you know,
coming to be,
I felt like a lot of empathy for that guy.
Not because I thought it was okay what he did,
but like I just start thinking about somebody with,
you know,
he's got two kids,
two daughters,
and like,
and I know that the answer to that is like,
well,
maybe you shouldn't have fucking done that then.
Yeah,
I get it.
Um,
and I'm not,
I'm not defending it or minimizing or diminishing what he did,
but it is,
um,
you know,
I can't help but like,
I feel like that is fucking devastating.
A price to pay,
you know,
it is.
And I think too,
um,
right,
like all crimes,
there's different levels of crime.
You have first degree,
second degree murder,
manslaughter,
aggravated robbery.
Yeah.
I think right now,
like to lump him in with a Harvey Weinstein.
It's not okay to do that either.
It's not the same crime.
Now is it a crime?
Absolutely.
Is it,
is it horrible and traumatic to have to go through something like that with a
dude?
Yeah,
of course.
And honestly,
how many of look as a woman,
have I seen dudes doing that in public?
Uh,
yeah,
every since I was 12 and,
and awake,
uh,
there's been dudes doing that.
I've ever said this publicly.
Yeah.
I have my own experience,
right.
With,
um,
uh,
a person who I worked for very early on in my show business career,
um,
living in Los Angeles and it was working for somebody in a position of power who
did something in a very inappropriate,
and I've told you about it.
I don't want to get into diesel and the,
I don't want to out the person either because I still know what the,
the end game that I'm looking for right there,
you know,
it's just like,
it's kind of one of those things where I just chalked it up to being like,
that person is fucked up and they have their own demons and you know,
I don't know what's going to happen to them,
but yeah,
it's been a long time.
It's been a long time,
right?
Yeah.
I just,
uh,
Nah,
man,
it's so fucked up.
I think what really breaks your heart and oh,
breaks our hearts.
I think you and I pacifically yeah.
Uh,
is that Louis is such a super talent too,
and you go like,
man,
that's the guy we all,
we all look up to as the gold standard.
It's one of those
things that people always,
you know,
bring up with these super talents that have these flaws or these,
like,
like you're Polanski's obviously a great director,
Ryan,
you know,
Michael Jackson was one obviously like the whole
yes.
Celebrated his talent and then there was like,
oh,
is he fucking kids all the time or something.
Like it's kind of crazy.
Or Kelly r Kelly's.
Yeah,
for sure.
Um,
you know,
he's a,
that's real talk man.
He really needs,
it's,
it's confusing and I think it is being caused was the worst because you're at
the same as a fan.
Like let's take it back a,
as a fan of these people,
it's,
it's such a psychological mind.
Fuck.
You're like,
wait,
am I allowed to like this person anymore?
I think the other part of it,
I think this affects people,
Gus,
with regards to Louis is that we're,
we work in his field and like,
you know,
Cosby's seems so separated from us because he's like 50 years older.
Right.
And like the way he came up.
But like we have like a certain bond with Louie because Louie is kind of like
the talent wise and like
kind of the Cosby of our era,
right?
Like he's the guy in the class ahead of us.
He's the class ahead us.
But we've seen him,
like we remember him having his first special yeah.
And seeing the trajectory,
seeing the build.
And so in a way he's like,
he's like the big brother even of Comedians who aren't friends with him.
Like you go like wow,
like look at him doing this and this and this.
You know.
So it's like you kind of want to,
we've all kind of been like in awe even if he's not your like I know some people
are like,
you know,
content wise,
they're not like into him or whatever.
Look man,
objectively,
skill wise,
he's such a skilled comedian.
Yeah,
it's wild.
Yeah.
It's a fucking bummer dude.
It's just,
it is the whole thing.
I mean it's sad.
I feel like that it happened.
Like it sad that he did that and sad for the women that experienced it.
But I'm also sad at the,
um,
like someone's,
you know,
life being just totally
ruined,
totally devastated right now.
Yeah.
Fuck.
And they try it,
you know,
and,
and lumping in the people close to him,
making it about,
like his manager is like,
I dunno what the fuck that's all about that and stuff too.
You're like,
well look,
the manager is only going by what he's been told by the client and it's the
manager's job to protect the client.
So you can't,
you can't be like,
hey,
the manager should have known,
there's a lot of things they're not omnipotent.
Yeah.
Like going to mislead the person that you're wanting to help you cover for it.
So he's not going to be like,
can I tell him everything that I did?
Here's what I went.
No,
he's going to be like,
I didn't really,
you know,
you,
of course he's going to minimize of most likely.
And if you have a good manager,
they're gonna fucking try to help you.
They're going to help you out of the mud.
So,
and he wasn't,
by the way,
he wasn't helping a superstar.
That's right.
At the time.
Right,
right,
right.
Or like,
yeah,
of course you're going
broken protect.
This was fucking a long time ago.
Yeah.
So I mean,
I'm not like,
I know people are already going to jump on us for the way that we're phrasing
this,
I guess.
But,
um,
I just feel like part of what's going on right now is there's like a hysteria,
which again,
the end result is that it's going to,
it's going to check people in power to really think twice before
yes.
All their moving.
And this is,
that's a good thing.
And this is a necessary move in the evolution of equality for women.
This is a necessary,
yeah.
I mean,
you're abroad.
Okay.
Uh,
but it is a necessary thing to do to start weeding out these jerk offs that are
abusing women,
abusing and molesting children.
By the way,
Corey Feldman's coming out and naming people and who in the 80s were molesting,
and he said,
this is a known thing that there are pedophiles and two that came out against a
spacey.
He was 14.
Yeah.
I mean there's a 14 year old boy and that's fucking unbelievable.
But it's,
it is a,
it is a necessary thing to get things more equal and to clean up the business a
little bit,
you know?
Yeah.
It's,
it's terrible.
The whole thing is devastating.
It's terrible,
man.
I don't know.
Oh God,
that's a lot.
I'll make you slap the mat in the bay.
That's the truth,
right?
Yeah.
All right.
That's enough.
Uh,
show show business.
You know,
we usually don't talk her to events,
uh,
but you know,
this is happening in our,
in our community.
So yeah.
Um,
maybe a half deal.
I could maybe a mix it up and,
or change the speed a little bit by I'm telling you that we finally got some
more,
she's retarded ministries from our listeners.
Oh,
thank,
thank God.
I mean,
she's retarded and machines will then have become the two smash hit songs of the
fall season.
It's really,
really taken over.
And you know,
there was some excuse retarded is that came in last week we played and some were
okay.
Some were better,
but there's some definitely better ones in this week.
I'll give you a couple of here.
He's a of
club mix
them solely.
Awesome.
What all of the clubs.
I like that.
Well,
I love it.
You can play that.
We could play that anyway.
Absolutely fantastic.
Um,
you actually could play that at any Oh,
you could.
Yeah.
It will be great if we could have that played at a club and then people halfway
through and be like,
wait a minute.
What?
What are they singing this song?
This is Tim from Australia.
You Ready?
Ready?
Okay,
go.
She's retired.
She's retarded.
Retarded.
Sounds
great.
Very good work.
And then the one I,
that's a great,
that's Tim from Australia.
Thanks Tim.
The one I've been waiting for,
I told you I met him,
uh,
finally a few weeks ago when I was in,
Austin Gaping Dad.
Wow.
He's sending some of the great hits of your mom's house music history.
Yes.
Celebrity in our,
on our show.
Oh yeah,
he's an o.
G and a.
He made a,
she's retarded.
So you know,
I feel like some of our producers,
our music producers on this are have earned it.
Yeah.
He's gaping dad.
He deserves it.
I haven't even heard it and I just feel like he deserves it already.
He always does a good job.
That's quality work always.
So,
uh,
here we go.
Ready?
Finally.
The world premiere of,
she's retarded from gaping dad,
mate,
mate.
Make a branch and get over it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Fire little fucking song.
You
got to get off.
I mean,
this is an epic
masterpiece.
Really has an incorporates so many of our favorites.
It really is.
I'll tell you what I'll do is this song,
is I just a full length song?
I will close this episode with that full Song Mega Bridge and get over it.
Briefly go over it.
But it's so great.
I like those too.
I know.
Do you know who scrim is by any chance?
You always say what one are you going to lick my scrim?
No,
I say scrum.
Hmm.
No,
this is a rapper.
His name is scrim.
Oh,
he also goes by suicide Christ.
Okay,
and he's in the suicide boys.
Oh boy.
That's not a bad name.
There's the dead boys.
Suicide was not a bad name for a band.
Well,
I want you to pay attention to what Scrim is saying here because I feel like you
could learn a thing or two.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi.
The whole thing.
Well,
they can.
Hey asshole.
Is this like I'm down to do it alone.
Motherfuckers think I'm sick.
I'm down to do it.
I did it before and it's pretty fucking nice.
Like I enjoy it.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
I like having like a,
like a black case with a fat ass spread spreading cheese,
like put it on my face.
You know what I'm saying?
Why?
Here's the stipulations.
If I'm going to do some shit like that.
Okay.
Pink Guy,
he got,
he's got some stipulations though.
Stipulation stipulations,
man can you know?
Sure.
Some shit like that.
Thank God.
What are the stipulations when man
fire herself?
No fog,
no far lane.
Even a pitch in front of me ever.
You might get sitting down with.
Cause if she farts in front of me.
Yeah.
At parties over like I'm breaking up with you right then man.
Wow.
No,
I could not have a relationship with scrim.
You could and you're also not black.
He said,
oh bitch with a black bit.
Sorry.
Right.
I meant I did hear that.
I'm sorry I didn't.
Yeah,
I was hoping he'd be an equal opportunity but liquor.
But he likes white bitches.
You better never fart.
So yeah,
you're out of the I'm Ariana running.
Yeah.
For screening.
For the stipulations of assays.
Yeah.
One of two things have to happen all at both things happening.
It just makes it better for me.
What's that?
Got To bleach to hate us.
Oh,
Scott.
A blockchain.
It's gotta be fresh.
Gotta be clean.
And I wonder what else can get it more clean and then bleach in them all the
fuck.
I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong,
matricide with the fucking car.
It's a carcinogen cleaner food.
I wouldn't want her to ride her fucking ass off some ass shit like y'all talking
about it.
It's wrong.
And beliefs off of them.
Okay.
But why wait a minute.
No,
he,
he likes uh,
black women,
but he's asking them to bleach their anuses.
It does actually skin bleaching.
Right.
You bleach your skin around your anus,
which is I imagine very painful,
I'm sure.
And if he likes the darker ladies,
why are you asking him to bleach it?
Light or it seems counter intuitive as what I'm saying you for a darker.
Right.
Why don't you paint your asshole black?
You know,
that's what I would say.
Can you pay for asshole?
But he does have those knuckle tattoos that I liked.
So I a lot of tattoos.
I do like those and he talks the way.
Yeah.
Or secondly,
if she gets like fresh,
like straight out the shower.
Well that's why I'm much easier dry on like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
so it's still sitting in ISS open.
So stuff like that.
Yeah.
Then I'm throwing her down and we're getting it in.
So he requires ass bleaching or suds in the hall.
I think it's much easier to wash your asshole then to get it bleach.
But he's saying suds still in there,
like soap is like,
he's just saying like your extra clean,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Then he doesn't really like eating ass.
I feel like he likes,
they went,
Oh,
you're saying that he should have like a little dirty little Tang.
Wow.
Well,
if you're into eating buttholes don't you want it to be kind of in a state of a
butthole?
He's then he's when he mans will lick a,
uh,
a forearm or a forehead.
Do you know what I'm saying?
What you're saying then the taboo is gone if there's no Tang on it.
Yeah.
Little stink.
Right.
A little bit.
But not a lot.
Right.
A lot.
It's too tangy.
Like a whole day of me.
Oh God.
Running around.
Would you like my butthole after [inaudible]?
No,
no,
but it's not stipulated that she has to have the clean shaven us.
Absolutely.
Hold on.
That's like automatic.
I never,
to me,
I thought that was just natural.
That's like automatic.
It's like,
bitch,
if you bend over and I see one little fucking hair isn't,
they get,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like,
Ooh,
Yay.
So he doesn't really like looking ass is what I'm trying to say.
He,
he's got all these rules and stipulations.
He's got high standards.
This Guy Scrim.
Yeah.
I don't think he really likes it.
I don't know if he doesn't really like it,
but he's got some,
you know,
he's like,
you better never fart in front of me,
but I've never see a fucking hair.
I can't deal with it.
It'd be bleached.
And that'd be soap.
Yeah,
he just got his,
he's got a very,
very clear preferences.
His standards are just too high for much.
I mean I can't get my B whole hair less.
I don't wax.
Wait,
why can't you get a hairless?
I don't wax down there.
I don't believe in pouring hot wax on my most sensitive parts of my body.
And then you can get it.
I won't,
I refuse.
I think it's cruel and unusual punishment.
I think it's,
it's,
I just won't do it.
Why?
For?
For what?
When I can use a razor.
So you'd be,
you still use a razor?
Yeah.
On the under carriage and I can get my pee hole,
I can kind of graze my ass hole to get,
I'm not very,
I mean,
you know me,
I'm not,
you don't have a lot of hair.
I'm not very hairy.
No,
I don't think compare it to,
yeah.
So it's not a big issue for me.
I built a bitch is a guy hair coming out everywhere I go.
I was with a girl was I thought she had a pair of balls in her pants.
Like I was like,
what is it,
what you're talking about?
So Harry Harry got the underwear and a bulge and I was like,
oh,
Cindy,
I swear to you.
She was so hearing that she had a bald and I was like,
Nah.
And then when the,
when the panties dropped,
it was just like dog.
I mean it was that,
what year was this?
70 64 I know.
It felt like it was,
I mean it was,
but she was just super hairy,
you know,
now.
But that what I'm serious.
What year is this?
What year is it?
Like,
Oh yeah,
maybe 2000 yeah.
Yeah.
So you'd think like you've gotten the memo,
that general societal consensus is shave or wax,
you know,
Trim it down.
I made sure she was,
I mean she was shaved where she needed to be shaved,
but oh,
you're saying like so strong.
Right,
right.
There's so much bulk.
Right.
And I mean she was just a Harry Harry broad.
Now you do the courtesy of a trimming up down there for I try to,
yeah,
try to trim it pretty,
I mean sometimes I'll forget and I'll look,
I'll be like,
oof,
now God,
I can see where my dog much hair.
That doesn't bother me per,
I don't care.
But do you know that the trend now for girls is totally bald?
Wait,
that's been for years.
I feel that.
I just heard about it on the Internet.
No,
I swear to God I,
I was reading something and apparently bald is where the party's at.
Nyu.
It hasn't bald been the thing that lasted 15 years.
Yeah.
But when I was a single girl,
when you and I started dating,
the landing strip was trend the norm.
So now I'm saying that the the Hitler is,
is gone now it's just totally baby baby.
Baby beaver has been around for a while and I I to tell you,
I had a few baby beavs not that like it doesn't,
it being hairless doesn't really do anything for me.
I prefer the landing strip.
I feel it as an adult,
as a mature.
Well maybe that's what it is.
I have pubic hair so I'm a grown man.
I had puberty.
It's weird.
It is kind of show this,
you shaved it like a little kid.
Yeah.
Nice.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I mean look,
I'm not one of those people that grows out in my armpit hair.
I do let the leg hair go cause it's blonde.
I think hairless Cox are weird,
you know?
Oh that's so weird.
Or when a dude shave like shaves a perfect patch over it.
Like when it's,
when it's really well you see that?
Yeah.
It's like he shaves like how I would shave a like a beard line church right over
Rican.
I'm Puerto Rican beard.
Yeah.
Isn't that weird over a Dong like it feels like it should be.
You can trim it down,
but I think that's for pornos the shaping of they look bigger on cameras and no,
but yeah,
but I'm saying like some of them are so meticulously shaving.
I'm like,
okay,
well I'm sexual.
Yeah,
it's a little much.
Yeah.
Maybe that's what it is.
Just feels feminine to be like,
I put the line here and then I used the ruler and then I moved here.
It was the same here.
It's like,
what'd you just trim that down and make it look like you're ready?
My sweetheart,
why don't you put a bow on it?
You know what I don't like is a personally like buff guys that shaved their
chest and then you see the growth coming alone or selling.
I just,
I'm like,
just have hair just out there.
I know some people are really anti here.
Look at me.
Look at my head.
You are,
I know.
I'm like a fucking space monkey shot on his face.
Second fight.
Crap.
I have to Fart.
When are we gonna get these mics?
Yeah,
it's been a while.
Um,
I did,
I went for it.
You know what it is?
I've been getting my hair cut by the same guy you've been getting your haircut
by.
I love that guy.
Everybody in her family goes to now.
Oh,
it was great.
And um,
we've done different things,
but then over the years,
this front area has thinned out.
And so I believe in like when you're thinning in an area and keep it short.
Yeah.
So we've been keeping it short,
but then the more that it thins out,
it's like I get a haircut and then a week later I'm like,
oh no.
It's just like glaringly thin.
Oh,
that's why you're doing it because you feel like the grow out is making that
show more?
It does.
I don't feel like it does.
So it's like a,
to me it's like just throwing the towel and go,
oh,
I'll just go shorter.
So the haircut lasts longer.
Oh,
I see.
I didn't know your reasoning.
I didn't know.
I didn't understand this logic.
I really,
really,
what do you think was happening?
You just want it to be like a cool guy.
Oh No,
I got an older dad and just go ahead and get your dad,
your dad cut.
You know,
I just feel like I'm getting haircuts that lasts 10 days.
I did not know.
That's why I think it looks great.
I think you're very handsome.
We're very like,
what's going on?
Why don't I don't like change?
And I walked in and I was a,
we think you're like different.
And I was like,
Oh shit.
I don't like change.
I've been with the same hairdresser since I was 20 years old.
That's 21 years I've been going to Allen.
No one else has colored my hair since.
That's only Allen.
Uh,
I don't like change.
And I like you to look the way I'm used to looking,
you know,
it doesn't look that it took me a while to get used to it.
At first I was shocked because I'm like,
that's a real dad.
Jason Statham my new husband.
But now I like it cause I feel like it's more rugged.
I feel like you're like,
oh,
you know,
you need to go hunt stuff.
It was the same haircut as me.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I knew I liked him for some reason.
Yeah,
same haircut.
So I want to bring up something we didn't talk about when we were on vacation
with your family and August,
it was your father's 70th birthday.
And
I don't think we reported this.
We did it.
We must have mentioned this.
Well,
we're going to do it again.
Yeah,
sure.
I think it's hilarious.
It's a good idea.
And it was the 70th birthday and both your sisters and their spouses and your
mother.
All of us were there and well,
why don't you tell the story because this is your brilliant idea was I did,
I first mentioned it or I first write it down for like a card.
I forget.
I think I mentioned it.
I think we were at,
I think,
cause we had dinners the night before and the night of his birthday.
And so it was all of us together.
I said,
Oh,
like mom,
dad turns 70 tomorrow.
Are you going to give him?
Uh,
are you going to 69?
I'm tonight.
And she goes,
[inaudible] 69,
[inaudible] 70.
And they go,
no,
are you going to,
are you going to give me a 69 tonight?
Because this is last night being 69.
And of course there's like giggling at the table.
And my dad's like,
Tommy shaking his head and then everyone starts laughing and she's like,
what?
What?
And she's like,
I said,
what an innocent my mother is.
She really doesn't know no idea what 69 is.
And so like then Maria is like,
ah,
it's something.
Uh,
and my mum was like,
sexually?
And she's like,
yeah.
what?
They're trying to be polite about it.
It's just,
and she's like,
please take me.
And she's like,
okay.
You know,
like a guy puts his mouth down on you and then you go down on him.
And he was like,
what?
So they're like trying to like paint the picture.
Your mom's head is exploding.
Like,
wait,
she can't put it together.
Even fathom what's happening.
And then I,
uh,
you know,
once you finally figured it out,
she was like,
oh,
and just,
you know,
rolled her eyes and was like,
that just sounds horrific to her.
It's like,
you might as well be like,
can
can dad shit in your mouth.
So.
Right.
But then,
uh,
later on I go,
hey,
you know what you should do?
Um,
when we get together tomorrow you should be like,
I'm going to go 69 year.
Your Dad.
And she was,
she was down with it did,
we had,
we had dinner and she was like,
I'm going to go give 69 nine.
So fun.
But I think,
by the way,
what would be really fun for our listeners,
if any of you,
this is how I propose you do it,
get a camera going or at least an audio recording,
but Campbell would be better and ask your mom regardless of her age,
let's say your mom is 47.
I'd be like,
Hey,
when dad,
when Dad's about to turn 70,
do you think you guys will 69?
No.
The night before his 70th birthday on the last night of him being 69.
Will you give him 69?
Yeah.
Will you guys,
well you guys 69 and just see if they laugh or they get upset
and like if they're over 70 just go like,
Hey,
when dad turned 70 did you 69?
Um,
I guess,
uh,
as a birthday present.
How birthday ever been?
69 for the last nine.
Yeah.
Or if your dad's dead and be like,
if dad was still here,
do you think you'd 69?
I'm on his birthday.
So stupid.
It's so stupid.
Well,
cause we were talking about it like,
remember when you were like,
you first heard about what 69 was and you were like 12 or 13 or whatever and you
were like,
Whoa,
we're going to do that all the time.
I'm married and with 69 I just thought that would be the mountain top by a man.
One day,
69 and it'll be the best fucking thing ever.
And then I remember doing it and being like,
this is just not as good.
Well,
because you're doing the work.
And trying to receive the pleasure.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it's not as good.
It's counterproductive.
I know cause you want to be like,
okay.
It's like eating and shooting at the same time.
Like you got to do one or the other.
You can't do both at the same time.
I mean,
you can,
you can't be,
you're not going to enjoy known for it,
but you know.
Yeah.
But you're not going to enjoy either one.
Fully true cause you're,
you're working,
you're doing work.
So it's as much effort.
There's a Jewish prayer for shitting.
No.
Um,
from blue ban.
I thought this was bullshit because I've never heard of it and I grew up Super
Jewish,
but it's totally legit.
Hey,
Schindler's was glass in the last episode.
You came across your discussion of the sacred releasing.
Yeah.
That was that guy that was talking about really being present for your shitting
and the need for prayer or squeezing out your chocolate dough.
Let me save you the work.
US Jews beat you to it.
Here's the English translation of the prayer,
usually referred to as the bathroom blessing.
Oh,
bless it.
Are you Lord our God,
King of the universe who fashioned man with wisdom and created within him many
openings and many cavities.
It is obvious and known before your throne of glory that if even one of the
cavities is ruptured,
her blocked,
it would be impossible to survive,
to stand before
you,
even for a short period of time.
Blessed Are you God who heals all flesh and ax wondrously the prayer is said,
well,
washing your hands,
post brown or yellow rather than during the act of elimination as been
suggested.
Tina,
let me preemptively satiate your curiosity.
If you have diarrhea at the blessing is recited after each instance of said
diarrhea,
f all the haters genes within Gillian Aka hungry tits.
Oh Wow.
That's,
I like jeans with an amazing,
that is interesting.
Why had this might be a good time to bring up my appearance on the Adam Carolla.
Oh my God,
this is real shit centric episode today.
Sure is.
It's what we do best.
Yeah.
So I did Carolla show you're,
uh,
promoting mother inferior with which,
if you have not yet seen a Christina's Netflix special mother,
inferior is uh,
where is it mother inferior where it can it be seen on Netflix net flicks.
You can see it all over any of the many hundred thousand countries that now have
Netflix and a,
it's streaming and it's,
it's really great and it's really well received.
And so you've been promoting it everywhere.
Um,
and it was nice to meet Adam Carolla because I've been listening to him since
forever.
I grew up here in la and back when he was on k rock doing love line and he's
also,
you know,
one of these podcasts,
giants,
man,
I mean sugar,
not crazy.
Yeah,
he's amazing.
Very,
very gracious.
Very kind,
very fine.
So it just spontaneously happened.
We were doing some topics and I happened to get into this with Adam and I
thought you guys might enjoy it.
Yeah.
Adam,
do you have a bad day situation or are you just oh,
mashing that poo in near for just rubbing it.
My,
my thing is is I will
time the toilet with the shower.
So you know,
I know shit.
The shower to shower.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've done that too.
Now do.
But you do a white before you go shower.
Right.
You don't just surprise myself,
you know,
I like to keep it fresh.
Depends on certain factors.
First of all.
I mean I cannot believe you on a brother out there as disgusting as you are if
so much in common.
Corollas.
Grandfather was Hungarian as well.
He loves chicken Paprikash and he shits to shower.
Now a lot of us are shamed,
ashamed about it.
But Ari Schaefer and Adam Carolla.
Yeah.
Arie and I,
we're all shit to shower people and I thought it would be nice for all the other
ones out there.
We can,
we can all feel safe knowing that famous people go shit to shower today as well.
I'd like to,
yeah,
if I,
if I am staring at,
if I'm literally just going to step off the commode in,
into the shower,
I'll save the paper.
Wow.
Oh you don't show it was so yeah.
Pool.
I'll
go dunk myself in the pool that's in there.
I'll give,
I'll give a hot water.
Good.
Hot Water Rinse down there.
Yeah.
Good hot water.
Not even an exploratory wipe.
See what,
see what happens.
I get it.
You know what I mean?
Been there and done that.
It's not my first ass Rodeo.
It's reminds me of wife Kate.
Remember what?
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm good.
Yeah.
Between skippy peanut butter and Jif peanut butter.
Which do you like?
Yeah.
Skippy and jiff was Charro and I called her.
Oh Geez.
What is,
it may not have been out there.
I liked
did
Jeff Schiff.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then,
um,
between the shaky parmesan cheese,
the Kraft one or the fresh shaved Parmesan,
which do you like?
Oh,
okay.
And then what,
tell me what you think of this,
because I've had this conversation.
So when Christina goes to the bathroom,
like goes Gaca.
Okay,
no,
no.
I need,
I need your,
I need you to weigh in on this.
So she goes,
she goes back,
uh,
and then she goes,
she gets up from the toilet and she takes a shower immediately without wiping.
Even once.
I swear to God,
I swear to God.
Marty was got a little bit,
can you please tell me why?
Why you think so?
Because it is the only one in the shower.
Showers.
Well she says,
okay.
She says,
wait,
wait.
She says that the shower,
the shower pressure cleans it for her.
Well that's it.
That's another thing.
But do you think you think it's disgusting?
It's disgusting.
I don't see the difference between doing what she does and just going got,
got in the shower.
Okay,
go.
We both have it.
I'm not saying to do that.
I'm saying I barely see the difference because it's true.
It's true.
It's,
there isn't,
but there is a difference.
I'm,
I do the Brown in the toilet and like Adam said,
and he bring,
he brought up a really good point is that you know what you're working with.
Yeah.
He knows he's,
I'm 41 years old.
I've been dumping my whole life.
I know what's going on back there.
I know.
I know what's happening.
It's an it's fine.
It's fine.
I did it today.
I did a shit to shower today.
I try to do it every morning.
Okay.
And what's wrong?
I'm trying to set the uh,
nevermind trying to do that.
There again,
problems,
you know,
problems make my dick soft.
Okay.
Uh,
another interesting thing Adam said is that he does not take it.
He doesn't like taking long dumps.
Does he say this here?
That's in the full clip,
just fall off the turnip truck or whatever else we could see.
I asked in front of,
I know to work with and I have,
so I'm so he likes to get it out of the way is what you're saying.
Right.
Expeditious.
He doesn't enjoy the moment.
He doesn't shop online like I do.
Like I do our grocery shopping,
I'll pop a few blood vessels when I'm sitting down,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want it to go that quickly.
Yeah,
I know.
It's like the me time.
Like we have a toddler,
we have two dogs.
Like,
it's the one moment I have the enjoying my life.
Right.
Um,
how about this?
Uh,
machines within question.
Oh my God,
I love it.
I'm Mommy's,
I've been practicing on what does this Cutler,
the killer clowns flow.
Am I reading this wrong?
Maybe I need to open it up.
No cutter cutter.
Uh,
and I've come to a mental block.
Oh,
that's the guy,
right?
He properly expresses his disgust for haters with the lines f the haters.
F all the haters then follows it up with the line much love know,
hey,
well,
which is it?
What's real?
What's fake?
Maybe he's denouncing haters while rising above it himself.
Could cutter be Jesus or is he just a terminators matrix?
Happy Halloween and Mommy's Brian G,
Geez.
Well,
what a great question.
I mean,
he's right.
It's paradoxical on the one hand,
f all the haters and then he's like all love.
No hate.
If you're wondering,
by the way why this computer is here,
it's smaller.
It doesn't have all the stuff that I normally do.
I had computer problems today has swap it out last second just to do this
episode.
Otherwise,
I'd be playing you some machines within.
But yeah,
but that is a great question.
I think it comes down to him just not being very conscious of what he's saying.
You don't think he's on top of what he's saying?
He's a stream of consciousness.
Oh right,
right.
It just comes to him.
My flows.
Yeah.
He's kind of in the moment.
I'm walking down the street.
Yeah.
Cause it is right there.
If the haters and all love.
He's just saying so reporting the news from is his mind.
Yeah.
That's what genius do guys.
They can't wow.
Why to compliment machines are then became a smash hit single and it's because
of him in parks.
That's true.
That's really true.
Um,
brainchild.
If you will.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll try to get more,
obviously if he keeps creating content,
we'll keep playing it here.
So maybe,
maybe we'll,
we'll see if he does something in the same vein later.
You know,
it's hard to do two hits in a row.
He reminds me of a little bit.
Tupac.
Yes,
I see it.
I see a lot of Tupac.
Yeah.
One arm question.
My boyfriend and I are hardcore black guys who love to fuck and love your
pockets.
We were thinking to you to,
to Y'all talk,
uh,
talk about how to almost people wipe and we got to talking and things.
Those with arms.
We had the question,
if a woman has one arm and gets a manicure,
does she pay full price?
What right questions looking forward to your infinite jeans,
wisdom machines within f all the haters.
Much love rub,
rub,
rub from Holly and bear in Texas.
That is a fantastic question.
Jesus.
That is great.
What do you think of it?
We once had a nanny offer us half price Reiki on our eight week old baby because
our son was only eight weeks old.
So normally $100 she could get it to us for 50.
I'm thinking the same logic would apply with half a manicure and it makes sense
half price.
What do you think?
Um,
I think it makes sense but there's really like,
I dunno,
there's only one way to really find out.
I think we should call a salon.
Yeah.
Tell them.
My wife only has one arm.
And how much would you charge her?
That's what I'm going to do because that makes,
it's actually a really excellent question and it's one we can find the answer to
Shane's with machines with Oh hey,
terminator terminator.
He says 16
again and get terminator gun here.
Go to one of them.
This one,
this one's called nailed it.
Nailed it.
I know.
Or that I pass by it.
So dumb machines with,
oh,
that's right away here.
I've got one here.
Hold on.
There's another one here yet again.
Can get terminated again.
F all the haters.
Haters.
Here we go.
I mean these people,
one of my business or what?
No.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hi,
how are you?
Good.
Um,
what do you charge for a manicure?
Yeah.
Um,
my wife,
I'm trying to surprise her.
She wants a manicure,
but she has one arm.
Does she have to pay full price?
Okay.
For her one arm.
And she has one foot,
so can she pay half of the pedicure price too?
You know what
is before like that dinner.
Okay.
Is that,
that's less than normal though,
right?
That's what I'm saying.
That's the discounted rate.
Yeah.
Cause she's got,
she's got one foot and she's got one arm.
Okay.
That sounds like a great deal.
I'm going to send her there.
Thank you.
All right,
well,
fair enough.
That's very fair.
Very reasonable.
A establishment.
Yeah.
So like I've never had that before.
That's kind of surprising to me that there'd be more people with appendages
missing.
I'm sure there's still only get their nails done.
Yeah.
I don't see why they wouldn't.
I saw a woman with severe arthritis,
um,
getting her nails done.
It was really hard,
but you still want to have nice nails.
Probably still want it.
And she had like Nice rings and stuff.
So he's still on a jazz yourself,
of course.
But that was a really good question.
Another good question that came in about Dick Tattoos.
No thought provoker Oh,
interesting.
On episode four 21 you talked about weird places for tattoos and mentioned the
poisoned Penis Tattoo.
I really thought about how that Tattoo session went.
I imagined the penis would be,
have to be hard,
but wouldn't.
The pain of the needle hurts so bad.
You'd lose your boner if you did lose your boner.
You think the artist made the client go to the bathroom to rub,
rub,
rub or did he close his eyes while the client rubbed that to get hard again?
How many,
well you know,
I wonder if anybody,
this is a,
she says you guys are doing good Kelly from Missouri.
It's a great question Kelly.
And if there's any tattoo artists that I've ever done a penis tattoo that could
enlighten us on how that goes and whether or not you have to be erect and if you
lose your erection,
cause I imagine that that does apply there.
You know for sure.
I would imagine flacid and then they would stretch the skin and do it set
because how could you maintain an erection?
But I don't know anything about tech.
I know a lot about dicks and I think about tattooing.
I imagine they like stretch the skin of the penis and then really get in there,
get like the way you're drawing on stretch those nooks and crannies.
Get the ink N.
Yup.
That's a good point.
I don't think it should be.
I,
but I'm not a tattoo artist.
You know,
by the way that when I played this in the earlier in the show,
did you know that that's one of the first drops we played and then this is
actually the same lady.
No,
but if the game
noticing this too,
they just ain't telling y'all damn man,
this boy told me to tell y'all.
Y'All need to watch on the y'all damn nuts and all around y'all damn nuts.
Yeah,
right.
And put this boy is saying to tell y'all it,
even if you do not get penetrated and have anal sex,
then you still have an obligation to lift your nut sack up and go all under
round the back.
And then they said all around your Dick too.
They said it dig be staking.
Yeah.
Isn't that like a it intuitive for everyone?
I mean obviously not because she's having to do a PSA about me.
She's saying like even if you don't engage in anal sex to wash your nuts and I'm
not sure what that has to do with anal,
but I don't know.
I think she's,
she's misinformed.
Yeah.
This shit got to stop.
He said,
y'all need to wash,
get out at hot,
kicked up crops and when y'all shit
particles,
the shit and pieces of tissue and shit
and don't just depend on that toilet tissue to do the trick.
Wow.
Was just a lot of information there.
It's very,
very important.
I feel like everything that she's saying is quite,
quite obvious,
right?
Yeah,
it's true.
It's like ladies and gentlemen,
wear deodorant.
Change your underwear every day.
Brush your teeth twice a day,
floss like,
dude,
we get it.
Who's not doing the basics?
Know,
maybe she's just pushing back.
Maybe this is push back against all of the fucking,
uh,
people that have for years now say,
oh,
pussy stink.
Wash your pussy.
Your pussy stinks.
Right?
She's heard that her whole life.
She's like,
fuck you wash your decking.
Which I understand that there is this thing about women's Vaginas just being
smelly,
24,
seven.
It's like,
really?
It shouldn't be unless something is going on,
infections or such,
but yeah,
I'm fucking sick of hearing how,
how stinky vaginas are.
They're not,
I mean,
there are sneaky boxes out there.
I'm sure,
but you know,
but what do you expect?
I mean,
come on.
It's the,
it's a portal of life.
You guys can't be perfect.
Come on please.
Here we go.
Well y'all bring y'all dick and nuts to go over there and go up in his butt and
go to his house.
We'll be back and we'll ask Alexis la,
I didn't know it was like this Nigga ass damn chain.
And y'all
say y'all ain't his motherfucking.
There you go.
So you're right.
You're right.
Tom,
why you called that one?
I tell you,
I know Dick's and eyeballs.
I know things that smell.
I know it.
That's why it's really my wheelhouse,
man.
It's really,
really good.
We have a dental update.
I mean,
what,
why would you even know why I let the dogs and the kitchen is there dinner time.
Just hold on
for,
I give you our listener dental update.
You've been saying and actually know what this first came up with.
You know,
obviously my friend fat,
uh,
Bert who,
um,
can you imagine if you've seen his mouth right?
All these,
it's a garbage dump.
Yeah,
it's just,
it's horrific.
And he,
he breathed his teeth.
Look like Thanksgiving corn.
Yeah,
the decoration white brown won a gold one.
It's all different colors.
It's pretty bad.
And He um,
he breathes really loud.
And you were talking about like,
Hey,
do you think you probably like,
I know he snores,
we should call his wife and be like,
yeah,
what's that snoring like?
Sure.
He doesn't wear a mouth guard at all.
And uh,
I've been wearing one for years,
which has helped tremendously.
You noticed,
you noted that lately?
My snoring has gotten louder,
but I think it's cause I haven't switched my bands out in the wild.
It's like a switch them out tonight.
I think you should because the last two nights I've had to poke you and then you
flip over now.
And I also think it might be time for a new mouth guard Bay because you've been
using the same one every night for how many years?
It's a few years now.
Yeah.
It's time.
It's time for a new one.
Go to the doctor,
the dentist and go get a fresh one.
Okay.
Or get get backups too.
Maybe too.
It's a good idea.
I'm surprised you haven't,
I don't want to jinx it,
but you haven't lost this one.
I've been,
I've had panic attacks about losing it,
so I probably should get it back up or make this the backup and get a fresh one.
Get a freshie.
You deserve it.
Thanks.
I'm going to do it.
I really love it.
And actually there are times now to say I get into a hotel and I'm like,
Oh,
I'm so tired.
I got to take a nap.
Yeah,
I just won't even open my bag.
I don't sleep as well.
Like I,
I mentally,
it's not as comfortable now cause you're used to that.
I'm used to it being there.
It's like wearing your retainer or your headgear,
you know,
this isn't a plug for,
I'm not saying,
I'm not telling you about one,
I'm just saying that like if you do snore and,
uh,
you want to have a more comfortable,
fuller night of sleep,
this is what has helped me and it helps the person that sleeps next to me
professionally.
Yay.
No,
you go to the doctor.
They did a mold done.
Yeah,
it's a whole thing.
The whole thing.
They're very upset.
All right.
We'll take them in a moment.
We're almost done.
Okay.
So yeah,
go ahead.
Here are,
um,
yeah,
I,
anyways,
I'm going to get it done.
You deserve a fresh one.
I'm brushing lot.
I floss my teeth whitened.
I will say that your teeth and your special look much wider and I think people
are really going to be dazzled by how thin you look and how white your teeth.
Well,
I definitely looked at,
if you look side by side,
the last one.
Yeah,
it's definitely different.
It's really,
it's,
I think people are going to be really dazzled by how great you look in this new
special,
especially.
Well,
I think if they did,
if they've never seen me before,
there'll be like,
who's that fat guy?
But if you know me from before,
you'll be like,
oh,
he looks better.
It looks way better.
Yeah.
Um,
here's another email we got.
We get done.
We'll updates all the time.
As a reminder to anybody who listens to the show.
If you ever want to send in the song,
if you ever want to send in the link,
if you ever want us to watch a video,
if you're want to give us an edit dental update,
the email is always don't do Facebook,
don't direct message.
Don't you always hit us up at the g mail address?
That's the official email address.
We have thousands of emails and they've all come in through there.
That's where we check them.
It's your mom's podcast@gmail.com we did.
There's no house in the address.
Your mom's podcast@gmail.com here's the email.
Hey Mommy's,
my name is Brandon and I have a dental update for you.
I've been listening to the show for a few years now and I used to fast forward
past the dental updates because I was ashamed of my teeth,
27 years old and my teeth were starting to look like I've been eating rocks all
my life.
I didn't have dental insurance,
so I didn't go to the dentist for over 10 years.
The early onset dad mouth was real and my jeans were pretty low and loose.
It got so bad that I wouldn't smile with my teeth and it was affecting my self
esteem and happiness.
After I got a new job with good insurance,
my triple d slut wife who has a great set of chompers on her convince me to go
to the dentist to see what we could do to get the ball rolling on fixing my
teeth.
That along with years of dental shaming from the main mommies.
Good,
good.
Finally made my appointment with,
so we started with a cleaning and I looked like a bloody mass after clean.
That lasted about an hour.
The dentist then did an evaluation.
I had 16 fucking cavities.
The good news is over the course of two months,
I got all 16 fillings.
I am now finally cavity free.
No longer ashamed to smile.
I didn't know how good the white fillings would look.
I just wanted to thank you,
Tom and Christina for shaming me for years and being a contributing factor to
force me to go to the dentist and making my smile.
Something not to be ashamed of.
You've had a positive influence on my life and I'm glad my wife and I found your
show on top of the teeth.
You helped me and my wife br gross ourselves ever making farts acceptable around
each other,
which has undoubtedly gotten us closer as a couple.
Anyway,
sorry for the long email,
but I just wanted to say sincerely thanks jeans Brandon from North Carolina.
How about that?
It's so true.
You know,
when I got my veneers done,
the gentlemen who did them sent that people have to relearn how to smile when
they get their teeth fixed because the,
the muscles actually go wonky because you're covering and teeth when you smell
or you don't smile at all.
I have a cousin like that.
I don't want to out them,
but I have a customer.
Could you imagine?
You're not smiling?
Yeah,
I mean we don't that often,
but it's not good.
I'm saying to restrict yourself from smiling this time.
Could you imagine psychologically it's very devastating.
It's gotta be devastating.
Um,
this is a,
I'm always a fan of a coach that goes over the top.
This is a youth co youth hockey coach.
Um,
Littleton Hockey Association removed.
Uh,
it's this,
this coach from the team.
This is youth,
a youth coach.
Um,
it has come to our attention of video involving one of our coaches.
and,
and one of their assistants has been circulating through social media
that says that they basically found this to be completely unacceptable.
I find it to be completely hilarious.
And this is the coach in the locker room given the pregame speech.
Okay,
I'm this kid right here,
ear to ear smile.
Like this is the best.
Like loving my coach talking like this.
Yeah,
it's going to be a good,
I don't see what's wrong with it,
honestly,
and he's fired up.
Am I wrong?
I know I'm wrong.
He also knows of the kids aren't threatened because they're like laughing.
They're laughing.
It's funny.
I have no idea where I'm headed with this.
You said,
fuck the other team.
Fuck their coaches.
Fuck their wives and all these kids go.
They can hear us.
That's the best.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
that's so great that that coach said something there.
He goes,
they're going to,
we're going to beat them so bad.
They're going to wish something.
The best version of that I ever heard was a football player one time said in an
interview.
He said,
I want to hit people so hard that they don't want to play football anymore.
That's a really good idea.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
I guess the most intense,
something like that,
but can I tell you something?
In order to win in life and in order to succeed,
you do kind of have to have that killer.
Oh,
this guy played in the NFL.
But that'd be thinking to think about that.
People say things like,
I want to hit guys so hard.
They shit their pants right.
I want to hit them so hard.
I knocked her helmet off.
This guy said,
I want to hit people so hard.
They don't want to play football anymore like they want quit the gang like that.
That's inspirational.
I don't,
it motivates me.
I feel inspired.
His name is Ernie Sims.
That's who said that?
Yeah.
My Dad used to say,
um,
uh,
fuck,
Oh fuck,
oh fuck cups with Lasik.
A fight.
I'm going to hit your head so hard.
It's going to fall off.
Oh Wow.
I'm going to hit you so hard.
Your head's gonna fall off.
All right.
Different a path that I was going down.
Yeah.
Let's talk more in sports.
Oh,
right.
But I mean,
it just,
it rung a bell in,
in me.
Yeah.
And inspirational.
That is inspiring.
Yeah.
And did that ever happen?
No.
No,
no.
Then that's,
yeah,
but they threaten you with it.
Hungarian go a long way though.
Yeah.
Threats are good.
Um,
yeah.
All right.
Well I think that's it for today,
gene.
It was definitely a fun,
by the way,
I forgot about skippy.
Skippy all day.
Fuckers.
Don't you just show me an Osha Jeff.
Crap.
Skippy all mother fucking day and shaky cheese all day.
There's a,
there's a bunch of songs,
but I have to close on the gaping dad song.
Yeah,
of course.
I mean,
it sounds here,
but it's like a medley of all great things.
Yeah.
It's so great.
Um,
thank you all.
Oh,
don't forget this.
By the way,
in our store,
the Christmas sweater is 100% profit to charity.
We're doing the children's Hospital of Los Angeles.
So there's multiple Christmas products and there's obviously other,
you know,
we have shirts.
I have signed vinyl,
mostly stories sign,
completely normal sign the vinyl,
there's albums,
there's shirts.
And we have,
um,
some,
uh,
holiday stuff.
Like Santa Claus is black.
Santa Claus is Asian,
Santa Claus is Latino.
And we have a Santa Claus wears jeans,
a hat,
like a winter hat,
you know?
Yeah.
It's great.
I mean,
the quality on it,
it's like a Sony.
It's the patterns sewn in.
It's not a bullshit thing.
But if you see the Christmas sweater that says Santa Claus wears jeans,
yeah,
that's all going to charity.
That's awesome.
So,
um,
and we'll,
you know,
we'll,
we'll document it will show you like however we get the toys or just give them
the,
the money.
It'll be like,
well,
we'll video it and put it up so you can see.
It will start your holiday shopping.
Now you guys,
these are going to go fast.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
the genes one will sell out really soon.
Yeah,
I'm for sure.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you guys again for listening and we'll see you next week.
Bye Jean.
My Mommy,
my mate mate.
Mate,
mate.
you Brandon,
get over it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Told you.
Tango started.
She's in your chart.
It,
you got to get on the phone.
You got to get off the phone.
You don't mind?
You don't mind.
Do you ever see your mom?
Yeah,
my mom.
You ever get your mom?
Yeah,
my mom.
My mom
started.
Pardon?
Hey.